Okay. So by now, you've heard a lot of
positive things about App Engine and how it can help
you build scalable applications. But let's do a reality check
here. Surely, there must also be trade offs involved when
using App Engine. Let's start off with programming languages.
Since App Engine provides services to control the execution environment,
it also has to set up programming languages it supports.
This list has been extended over time, but App Engine
currently supports Python, Java, PHP, and Go.
And since App Engine is an execution container,
it also means that there are specific versions
of these languages that are supported, so this
is something to think about. Then moving over
to low-level controls. Since App Engine was designed
to create scalable application as easy as possible,
it's execution environment also encapsulate many low-level controls.
For example, operating system type and version, virtual
machine configuration, or network controls, et cetera are not
visible, and cannot be configured in App Engine. And
that goes for other things, as well. App Engine
strikes a great balance between providing the convenience you
need to develop scalable applications without sacrificing the flexibility
that you want. But with this in mind, don't
be surprised later on when you see App Engine
is not like a regular virtual machine, because it's not. All right. That's
it for the reality check. Let's now look at some App Engine success stories.